what a stupid sound of [ __ ]
and we will ban men
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.
and 99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't mangoes like
three boxes
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identifying from the
mangoes
forcefully affected the american people
[Music]
is
[Music]
all right an incredible day for
advocates of fruits and vegetables uh it
is uh truly truly an historic day
what a show i have for you today i am
glad that you are here and we are going
to be talking about so many different
things another one of these very
volatile days in the stock market where
we had green
all across the board all day
until the fed's announcement that
there's no change to the federal fund
rates federal funds rate today
but expect the change in march and
collapse
and i know a lot of people saying well
but sir it only ended up down a little
right but it was a very very up day and
continued volatility now do i care well
i mean sure i i care
because of what volatility points to in
the economy but
i know all these people including many
people in my audience who are like oh
david you know you could have made money
today if you shorted at 1 pm and then
you bought back in
guys come on you know i don't do that
i'm not doing that stuff
maybe meet kevin is doing that i don't
know what he's up to these days although
i get reports
uh that he's doing a lot of crazy stuff
but um come on guys you know that that's
uh that's that's not the way i roll and
so i'm just holding collecting dividends
and that's it but continued significant
volatility
um
and if we look at the five day just uh
all over the place and of course the
month still looking quite not so good
but but
yeah exactly
uh okay so that's what's going on with
the stock market and coming on a day
where we learned that joe biden will be
getting a supreme court pick as the 83
year old stephen breyer
will indeed be retiring and guys listen
i don't know
but if we're down to the last nine
months before a midterm
i don't know if it's okay to let joe
biden pick a replacement to the supreme
court right i mean that sounds very very
suspicious like you're gaming the system
in some way
not to mention the you know we've got a
waning moon and it's an even day of the
month and when that happens i'm pretty
sure bo bear gets to pick the the
replacement
but they are starting that
i'm joking around but they are starting
that and we're going to get to that in a
little bit i see
uh folks asking about phones i have not
even talked about this recently
but
i will open phones at 100 today we've
been getting 70 without me dangling
anything like a carrot
so i will do um
i will i will open phones if we get to
100 and kicking us off i mean we're
already kind of making progress i want
to say thanks to king titus
word fencer cosmos
jen here
magnum satan has gifted
five five and four hold on five and four
is nine nothing to carry that's nine and
then jen here gifting one that's 10
putting us at 10 already
yeah we'll open phones at 100 why not
and of course the the best best best way
to support
is uh to sign up at joinpakman.com and
you can use the coupon code obama to do
so obama
and we will ban men
super chat sir thank you for being a
reasonable voice in politics keep it up
and could i get a sir your wife is up in
the air sir your wife is up in the air
exactly
um
yeah excuse me i'm getting a call on my
obama phone exactly oh and thanks to
blueberry babe for gifting a
subscription as well blueberry babe's
been on fire lately with the gifts which
i appreciate okay saturday i hope that
you will join me at seven wait no hold
on
what seven yeah i hope you will join me
at 7p east
4p west
because we will be
in conroe texas i won't be
but we have a correspondent who will be
in conroe texas
interviewing trumpists guys they we will
have someone on the ground then he went
donald trump yeah donald trump right
and so by proxy i will be interviewing
trumpists on saturday before the rally
and i can't wait
to talk to some of these folks we are
lining it up when i when i said if
anybody lives near conroe
and you want to go down there we will
pay you and etc we had a bunch of
responses and i think we're getting
close to finalizing the plan and i think
it's going to be absolutely fantastic if
people have suggested questions like for
if so one question would be like
did trump invent the vaccines and if
they say yes then i would say are you
vaccinated and then if they say no i
would say can you can you explain that
to some degree
um
what do you expect to learn at today's
rally i think would be interesting
um
yeah so anyway if you have suggested
questions
you can let me know
um
it could be pretty compelling content
it could be pretty compelling content
that's for sure thanks to it's me john b
for gifting a twitch subscription i
appreciate that
uh let's see we're at 12 so what
percentage is that if okay let me think
if we're trying to get to whoa i think
my desk almost just collapsed
oh my god
what on earth just happened my i almost
had a complete and total collapse here
if we're trying to get to a hundred and
we're at 12
there must be some easy way to do that
that's like 6 50ths
or three twenty-fifths how can i reduce
that into a percentage let me hold on a
second
it's twelve and a half percent right
twelve out of a hundred is i think it's
twelve and a half percent
oh it's twelve percent oh that's weird
okay
um let's continue
so yeah that that's um that's on
saturday and i think it's going to be
really good i think it's going to be
really good
daniel says not sure if it makes a
president to make a scotus pick in the
same decade as an upcoming presidential
election let the people decide i agree i
think the voices uh i think we need to
allow the people's voice to be heard
um before joe biden selects select
anybody thanks to blueberry babe for
another gifted sub as well as shaved
panda putting us at 14. don't keep
making me no don't make me make do more
math here
david sir i've been faxing you about
your illegal coupon codes i've been sued
by the biden regime because of them we
don't have a fax machine so you must be
you must be faxing someone else what's
your take on dan ball from oan asking
from dirt on william canard i don't know
who either of those people are i i'm
sorry i don't know what that's about
oh thanks to green man for re-upping his
sub
zero hour and skittle stew gifting five
fourteen plus seven okay fourteen plus
seven seven plus four is eleven
carry the one one okay 21.
i think we've got it
david sir saturday is my birthday any
thoughts on what sort of gifts i can
expect from the rally perhaps a display
of severe dementia right
um let me see here let me give you a
little something
fresh vegetables right if ivanka weren't
my daughter perhaps i'd be dating her
cephei
sefer hide
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times that's what i'm expecting at the
rally
david sir i've had coveted three times
only survive because i'm triple vaxxed
how do these stable geniuses not believe
in science well i'm sorry to hear that
meg
sorry to hear that
uh oh whoa hold on a second somehow it
says 121 there we go
all right let's move on to the supreme
court oh sorry no carlin evans just
signed up on my website with the coupon
code obama
and that's number 22. all right 83 year
old stephen breyer will be retiring from
the supreme court joe biden will get to
select a replacement
what are conservatives saying well you
oh hold on let me get to that later
conservatives are saying all sorts of
different things one idea that they have
is that joe biden in order to unburden
himself of kamala harris
is going to
make her a supreme court justice because
he has pledged to nominate a black woman
now before we jump into that let me
mention i've gotten a lot of people who
are saying david what do you think about
this whole
he is committed to nominating a black
woman i'm going to talk more about this
tomorrow
but what i do want to say is
you all know i'm not big on identity
politics i don't believe in using
identity as a cudgel
or to silence people or
whatever i'm just not for that
i also recognize
that when there's never been
a black woman on the supreme court
there would be meaning and power to that
now
some people on the right like to say
is this any different than saying i will
only put white people on the court well
it is different
it is different even as someone who is
against toxic and corrosive identity
politics of course is different because
almost everyone on the supreme court has
been white
and for a while we had a white supreme
court and legal slavery so yes there are
historical reasons why it's different to
say
i'm committed
to nominating the first obviously
qualified you know all this different
stuff black woman to the court
then someone who says i'm only
nominating white people it's not the
same thing okay
uh i'm not big on the entire identity
politics thing although i think it would
be interesting to see first black women
have there been asians on the court i
don't know native american
uh yeah i i just don't know okay but so
i'm not like all bent out of shape about
it
um but in any case so now the the whole
thing is he's gonna select kamala
so he doesn't have to run again with her
here's peter alexander ginsberg none of
that you can share i'm not going to
detail internal planning from here no
okay and let me ask you a couple other
questions is there any scenario in which
the president would select his vice
president kamala harris for the supreme
court
again i'm not going to speak to any
considerations preparations lists
and as we've stated earlier and you
heard the president say it is there's a
long history of supreme court justices
determining when they may retire if they
retire and announcing that
and we're going to uh that remains the
case today so the fact that she didn't
say get the hell out of here on the
kamala thing has now generated even more
discussion and here's peter douchey
following up talked about isn't an
initial package okay thank you good
thank you when you were asked about the
vice president possibly being selected
as a supreme court nominee you said
you're not going to speak to any
considerations does that mean she is
being considered
again peter i'm not going to speak to
the reports of a supreme court justice
retirement that hasn't been announced so
theoretically
even though the retirement hasn't been
officially announced and she's saying
nothing the fact that she's saying
nothing means maybe kamala harris is
going to be the nominee come on guys
theoretically i do like that you preface
it i appreciate it just wondering
hypothetically theoretically would
someone who was an attorney general of a
large state and who served with many key
senate votes be an attractive candidate
to the president for an open supreme
court i see what you did there peter but
the president has every intention
of running free of re-election and for
running for re-election with uh vice
president harris on the ticket as his
partner uh but again i will just
reiterate uh that uh i have nothing more
to offer in terms of specifics or
information on the reports this morning
i don't know
would you have another question yes
please proceed governor next next
question please please proceed governor
exactly
um
okay
so there's that then um here's
is it tommy lauren tomi larin i just i
don't know how to pronounce her name i'm
sorry guys
you guys know who i'm talking about
she now
had an idea about um
nominations of black women
yeah it doesn't change the ideological
makeup but we know that what joe biden
does best is placate to the radical
element and the radical placate ii now
that's not appropriate uh syntax i hope
i i know everybody on twitch and most
everybody on youtube knows that
but okay
progressive base of his party that he
believes is the majority i believe he's
incorrect in that i believe that they're
actually the minority but i'm wondering
the kind of justice that he would
nominate now again i'm sure it will be
as guy said a black woman you know he's
got a dedication to that we saw how well
that worked out with kamala harris but
here's to hoping that he has what does
that even mean
like i don't even know what she's
talking about
um
a better choice in mind for this
position but i would just hope that he
would choose somebody that is not only
qualified but maybe somebody that's not
so far on the route with that accent
qualified qualified what is that go left
i think the american people are making
it pretty clear that the woke-ism that's
going on right now in the democrat party
is not for them
so there's another uh suggestion
and then and then and i know you guys
were ready for this i know that you guys
are ready here is harris faulkner saying
i don't know i mean
we're kind of getting close to an
election here guys so i really want to
get into some of what we've seen though
uh guy and and that is this idea that
it's too close to an election uh-oh to
get something like this through for a
president we've seen it among
republicans we've seen democrats do this
as well um
it's january right and you can't miss
the time and it's almost february really
i mean it's it's i don't know guys think
of how far out that is from november
right it's not march it's not may so on
and so forth what do you make of how
much time president biden would have to
put something through and as kaylee just
pointed out you pretty much have to pick
somebody perfect at this point
the pres i don't even biden has better
do this perfectly or he is not going to
be allowed to do this either because you
don't have a stall time
let's also not forget that biden
promised on the campaign trail that no
matter who
retired or died from the court if he had
an opportunity to replace that person on
the high court he would pick a black
woman so that narrows the field of
potential names probably being discussed
right now in the white house i would
imagine that there are a lot of
conference calls and zoom calls between
the president's team and the senate
majority leader to make sure that they
don't screw this up right now they have
the votes in the senate i would imagine
the democrats are probably going to
stick together on this one and they will
replace justice breyer likely with an
african-american woman i think they'll
have the time to do it i think they will
maybe barely have the votes to do it and
i think yes it is true kailey's point is
right that this would be a victory uh
for the biden administration and for the
president yeah the the you know sadly
it's not as big it's a it would be a
victory in that briar's 83
and so you put someone on there for some
period of time depending on their age
it's not a victory in the sense that
replacing ruth bader ginsburg with amy
covet barrett is was
because you're flipping a c and i was
actually reading some pretty interesting
commentary i'm gonna think more about
this but i'll talk about it probably on
tomorrow's podcast
if i were whoever right like if i'm what
whatever black pers black woman they are
considering
um
and i know that it's gonna continue
being a six to three court
i almost don't want the position now i'm
not saying i turn it down no but what
i'm saying is you're going to be put in
there to be on the court during some
inevitably disgusting decisions that are
going to reflect on this court you won't
you won't be in the majority on them
you'll be in the minority
but um it's not going to be a good
period of time now of course eventually
if the timing works out you you replace
some conservative justices with liberal
and then you have a new coordinate and
etc but it's still going to be 6'3
and you might end up being there during
during some absolutely gross
supreme court decision so that's what we
have going on there we'll talk about it
tomorrow
um
oh here's a little more about the kamala
harris
hypothesis divisive in america right now
not bringing us together with this
further divide but you said something
too that i thought was really
interesting so this person has to be a
woman she has to be black and she's got
to be younger anybody thinking what i'm
thinking they don't know what to do with
kamala harris in the white house right
now i can't be the only person seeing
this and you have read i'm sure you have
kaylee because you and i have chatted
about it we've been reading that that
maybe something like this could happen
with the vice president he runs again at
someone else look
i prefer to drink my tea rather than
read the tea leaves but when jonathan
hurley turley excuse me puts out the
information of young black and female
it's hard not to see at least she makes
the list
kaylee
i think you're right i'm glad you said
that harris because that was playing in
my mind from the moment uh we heard
about this retirement you know it is
politically speaking if you are not
happy with your vice president and you
want her in a different role there's no
greater role than on the supreme court
all right so anyway they think it's a
plausible a plausible thing that might
be going on and instantly
donald trump starting to fundraise on
this check this out save america pack
breaking supreme court justice breyer
announces retirement joe look look at
the transition into the fundraising joe
biden will fill the vacant seat with a
liberal activist president trump has
activated an emergency 5x impact to
defend his america first legacy
please contribute any amount immediately
to claim your 5x impact and to save
president trump's legacy and god bless
the united states
and as you can see if you make a
contribution of 45
your total impact is 5xed
um
does that math even add up because isn't
five times 45
um
225
oh but i get oh i see so you do 45 and
then there's another 225. so yeah i got
okay okay okay i got it
um
man that is really weird stuff one of
the wettest we've ever seen from the
standpoint of water
so there's the trump grift
here's something really interesting
fox news host dan bingina
has been permanently banned from youtube
now this is really wild
while we were streaming i just got a
message
from bangina's producer on fox
wondering if i want to be on
uh af aft announcing a partnership with
newsguard i don't know what on earth
this is about should i do that
that seems interesting
i shouldn't do it oh my god
it seems worth doing
i could even say mr bangina
during the thing
um all right we're going to look at it
later no i wouldn't be platforming him
i'd be on his show everybody relax
please please please so fox news host
dan bangina has been banned from uh from
youtube
fox news host and right-wing radio
kingpin was permanently banned from
youtube on wednesday after allegedly
attempting to evade a previous
suspension we terminated dambangina's
channels for circumventing our terms of
service by posting a video while there
was an active strike and suspension
associated with the account when a
channel receives a strike and oh hold on
wait a second i know i've got it
right strike and strike and strike and
strike and strike when a channel
receives a strike it is against our
terms of service to post content or use
another channel it's called ban evasion
the channel's terminated the uploader is
unable to use owner create any other
youtube channels nearly two weeks ago
vangina was temporarily suspended for
peddling coveted disinfo miss info
specifically claims that face coverings
are ineffective
he owns shares in rumble did not
immediately request to the daily beast
request for comment on instagram he
wrote the banned by quote youtube
communists was quote hilarious
punctuated by a poop emoji okay
so
[Laughter]
dear god what is happening to this
country
um
brandon says remember when trump tried
to pronounce yosemite yosemite yeah
it was something else
i want to say thank you to carl dirks
for signing up on my website with the
coupon code obama obama you were number
23 today
also over on twitch thanks to
herzfat
asking about the racist rant at a
smoothie shop in connecticut no i l i'll
remind me of that when we get to
the public freakouts okay herzefat von
vederveld gamevine
a pet giraffe
and cow crapper wow have uh made twitch
prime subscriptions putting us at 28 i
want to remind you guys we will open
phone lines today if we get to a hundred
and or
if we get to a thousand twitch subs we
have not been in the four digits
uh twitch subs for
feels like a decade it's probably been
about three months so either way we will
open phones i also want to say thanks to
joseph abbadi who just signed up on my
website with the coupon code facebook
and his new member number 29 today uh
let's not fail here oh and captain
smiles has gifted five
putting us at 34 which we love okay
couple other things i got a very unusual
voicemail from troy york recently and
troy york
is ranting to me about what's happening
on kyle kolinsky's show i don't know why
he would be doing that i i just have no
idea people call me and they complain
about other shows sometimes people call
sam sader they complain about me i don't
get it i really don't but let's see if
we can even understand what troy is
talking about here
kyle klinsky is a clueless gullible
stupid son of a [ __ ] and a piece of
[ __ ]
um
he doesn't know what the hell he's
talking about but why don't you call him
why are you calling me
he lies saying that
uh crystal cinema has eight percent
approval rating
is crystal cinema a portmanteau of
crystal ball and kirsten cinema he just
talks and gets the all of his ass
because kyle kalinski is a progressive
punk ass [ __ ]
who lies and misinforms in every video
he does like
what a stupid
song there's not a grain of salt of
truth
in anything he does on youtube i i don't
know how this guy even has a channel
he's funny but
um the fact is crystal cinema
um
likely will run again and she's going to
win
and his assertion that she's just gonna
go it's like why would you call me to
tell me kyle's view on crystal cinema is
wrong it's just like
just call kyle i mean i don't know
it's very strange
and uh get some big corporate job
well that's uh
uh something that
happens with a lot of politicians but um
this woman has integrity courage and
bravely and she
and joe manchin and any politician
uh and the democrats don't have enough
that would be nice if they had more but
any politicians like maybe comment on
kyle's youtube channel i don't know why
you need to call me
that stands up
to this dribbling brain maniac
dumbass
mean tempered
short fused
um low iq
jackass maniac in the white house joe
biden anyone who resists
this idiot and his stupid program that
not a joke are in the long run attempt
to spread communism socialism all right
anyway it goes on for two four two two
full additional minutes
i'm not gonna play it for you
but
i have nothing to do with kyle's show
you know don't don't call me
lovely planet sends a super chat it's uh
did you hear about the door-to-door
white nationalists in alabama i only saw
tiktok no one picked it up but it's
still pretty wild i didn't hear about
that
i did not hear about that
thanks to lauren triple 7g as well as
foxtrot for the twitch subscriptions
putting us at 36
we will open phone lines today if people
want also on my website aidan benny has
just signed up using the coupon code
obama
and his new member number 37. if we get
to 100
or we get twitch to a thousand
we will open phone lines but i have so
many more things to talk about that i'm
gonna keep moving okay we did stocks
we did briar oh this is fascinating so
earlier in the week i told you guys
about this completely outrageous um
anti-vaxx rally that took place in dc
and how i bobby kennedy jr
compared um
actually quite frankly said that the
vaccine mandates are worse than the
holocaust and talked about how anne
frank at least could hide in an attic
remember anne frank was ultimately found
and killed
um and he's married to cheryl hines
that's cheryl from uh curb your
enthusiasm
and she came out and denounced her own
husband and said my husband's reference
to anne frank at a mandate rally was
reprehensible and insensitive the
atrocities that millions endure during
the holocaust should never be compared
to anyone or anything his opinions are
not a reflection of my own so she
denounced that now of course it wasn't
really a mandate rally they had people
saying vaccines cause autism it was an
anti-vaxx rally but it sounds like
there's trouble in paradise and
reportedly this is not the first
disagreement on vaccines i guess you
know he's this big anti-vaxx guy but i
guess at their holiday party cheryl
required everybody to be vaccinated so
it's all kind of uh
i don't even know how else to react to
it you know
[Music]
yeah here's the um
let me see hold on
rob here's the original clip even in
hitler germany you could you could cross
the alps into switzerland you can hide
in an attic like anne frank did
i visited in 1962 east germany with my
father
and met people who had climbed the wall
and escaped so it was possible many died
truly but it was possible
today
the mechanisms are being put in place
i will make it so none of us can run and
none of us can hide right
he's referring to some people have to
get vaccinated as part of their jobs
that's if you're wondering like oh my
god there's some grave injustice going
on and people could die
he's talking about some people to keep
their job you got to be vaccinated as a
matter of policy
within five years guys he has vocal
dysphonia we're not gonna make fun of
his voice let's let's let's deal with
what he's saying he's saying being
required to be vaccinated is worse than
the holocaust okay we don't i'm not
worried about his voice i see 415
000 low orbit satellites
bill gates says his 65 000 satellites
alone
will be able to look at every square
inch of the planet 24 hours a day yeah
all right so anyway um
the uh here's here's his wife saying uh
does not speak for me certainly does not
speak for me
um jd straightshot says i was trapped
inside my carhartt bibs when i set them
on fire seventy percent second degree
burns on my body also lost all my green
m m's in the fire that's very very
nicely done uh jd very very very nicely
done i wanna say thank you to stop the
squeal and sterling lana who between the
two of them have donated eight twitch
subscriptions putting us at 45
also thanks to billy carpenter and jeff
builds a base for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 47 we are
already close to
that's about 47 out of 100s like 48
percent we're getting really really
close here really really close to
opening uh opening phone lines all right
we took care of that
we did the dan bonginose thing oh all
right so now we're going to get into
some public freakouts in different
situations what was the thing someone
asked about earlier it was a was it a
merrill lynch employee
i think that's what let me see if we can
find that with a racist rant
meryl
lynch racist because i want to include
that
that's not coming up
is merrill lynch two l's
uh
no
oh here it is
merrill lynch advisor fired after racist
tirade at a smoothie shop oh okay
yeah so that i want to look at
let's take a look at it here
ooh this website is toxic does anybody
have an actual video oh i'm spelling it
wrong oh no wonder
merrill lynch racist
here it is okay all right let's let's
start with that i have a bunch of these
that i want to go over i have so many
things for you guys today
um let's start here yeah i have no room
to yell enough i want to speak to the
[ __ ] person who made this drink is
that you no i don't know who made it so
you know who made it there's four of us
here so we honestly don't know stupid
[ __ ] ignorant high school kids okay
bye i want to speak to the puppy hi okay
you can call corporate whatever you want
goodbye
you're on camera
i don't care
give it to me right now
now does it when does it get racist
[Music]
oh my god i'm calling the police i'm
calling the police
and why is he mad something was wrong
with his smoothie does anybody know what
like
was it a legitimate smoothie problem
that would justify this like for example
they poisoned it on purpose or was it
insane
did he say indian what where is the
racism part
okay good for
get the [ __ ] out get the [ __ ] out get
the [ __ ] out oh god this guy looks
i would have guessed this guy was in law
enforcement from his appearance not uh
not not merrill lynch
damn you're going to jail you racist
piece of [ __ ]
oh my god is he trying to push his way
into the back bro call the police now
wow okay yeah so that's that's pretty
aggressive
uh it was related to a nut allergy okay
all right well that's a legitimate
concern i don't know that the immigrant
status of any individuals is relevant to
that i want to say thank you to chandler
who just made a patreon pledge patreon
counts double so that puts us at 49
today and i really very much appreciate
that all right let's continue
here is a hero illinois librarian this
is an elderly
uh woman who is standing her ground an
anti-massacre through a tantrum
because they were asked to wear a mask
and here is a hero librarian
if i learned one thing guys
you don't want to mess with librarians
oh then wait hold on the merrill lynch
guy uh got fired let me see
merrill lynch smoothie fired i want to
know that
oh that's delightful man that is the
best
oh i love that i love it when this stuff
happens oh and he was arrested too hold
on let's just complete that
merrill lynch wealth advisor arrested
hey bill you got those bonds for me no
i'm fired merrill lynch wealth advisor
arrested and fired after calling a teen
smoothie shop worker an immigrant loser
and throwing a drink at her james
yanazzo said he was upset after his son
suffered an allergic reaction a merrell
rep said our company does not tolerate
behavior of this kind you love to see it
guys
you love to see it called her an effing
immigrant loser
the fairfield police department received
numerous calls ooh fairfield connecticut
i hate to say this but i i've spent
quite a bit of time in connecticut
these places places like fairfield
greenwich new canaan
um
they have endless beautiful great people
and a lot of toxic people like this guy
fairfield police department received
numerous calls at robich's smoothie
outlet
uh with workers complaining a customer
was throwing things yelling at employees
and refusing to leave
an investigation revealed that james
yanazo 48 ordered a smoothie earlier
requesting it be made without peanuts
sent as an allergy
he said that
the employees said that while he
requested a smoothie without peanut
butter they were not told about the
allergy
his son suffered an allergic reaction
and had to be transported then he showed
back up to say who made the drink they
didn't know
the confrontation escalated as we saw
um
wow
he worked at merrell for 26 years
there has been only one allegation
against him in 25 years
he was once ranked by forbes as one of
the 25 best
connecticut wealth advisors
okay
he was charged with intimidation based
on bigotry or bias in the second degree
breach of the peace criminal trespass
and he has a court date
meryl lynch rep bill halden said our
company does not tolerate behavior of
this kind we immediately investigated
and have taken action this individual is
no longer employed at our firm it's the
correct outcome i mean you know it's
it's the correct outcome
hard to uh
hard to imagine any other okay let's
continue
let's check out the librarian shutting
down the anti-massacre so i just want to
take a video and ask why you won't
let me sign up
no this is your choice to do this this
is this is serious
i'm here with my serious daughter
we just want to use the library that we
have the right to use
and you guys won't
let it right now you can't go into the
library naked just because your taxes
might fund the library it doesn't mean
it's a free-for-all you can't just do
anything in the library libraries still
have rules let's do this
because i'm not putting a mask on
that is our library
it's just so simple like how do people
not understand
it's the policy
we have a mask policy right now
that's it
that's all that's all it is to make the
personal choice
to say it's not a big deal i mean i see
you have two masks on so you clearly
think it's a big deal but
that policy we have to abide by
no you don't you're making the choice
and just acknowledge that i'll leave
here but just acknowledge that you're
making the choice
you're just following orders and that's
the problem
that's the problem with all of this yeah
it's like a nazi ss guard just following
orders you know it's the same thing it's
these people are out of their minds
you really ought to think about that
it's a shame
it's a shame
seriously
all right so anyway
um
kudos kudos to this librarian who uh was
not having it was not having it at all
and uh he ended up leaving of course
super chats continue to come in did you
see the video of gina bisignano beverly
hills barbie charged insurrectionist
destroying property with spray paint on
beverly hills homegrown terrorists has
the details on instagram
that sounds pretty interesting
let me check that out
just while we're doing this um
homegrown terrorists
uh
all right let's take a look
a lot of people going bonkers
let's see
is it under does anybody know where
which one of these it is
is it in a story or
yeah i'm just not i'm just not sure
where it is
anybody know
is it under videos exclusively
pipe bombs no it doesn't seem like it
under b for bonkers yeah
okay
we'll come back to it if someone can
then tell me exactly where it is we can
come back to it here's a couple others
here are employees at holy chow oh i
like that holy chao
in maryland
standing their ground against
anti-massacres call them the nazis
everybody's a nazi these days have you
guys noticed that um bobby kennedy jr
said it's worse having to get a vaccine
is worse than what happened to anne
frank
um
anyway okay let's take a look at this
one
you don't have to i'm not trying to
argue with you right now
everybody's talk everybody's talking at
once it's already impossible to figure
out what's going on
already
he's going to roll with him
he doesn't know he doesn't know
which means that we are not allowed to
assert you if you're not in this world
segregation was legal
segregation oh my god
the holocaust was legal oh my god
yeah we need three sets of subtitles at
once for this senior service okay
we infected everyone
that's against this guy's religion he
only would wear natural fibers as as
indicated by the old testament
there it is just following orders like
the nazis okay all right so that i'm i'm
bored with that one second and fourth
post on instagram okay
let's see second why are you giving gina
a hard time she didn't damage anything
she supports herself okay so this is the
fourth let's see what we got here
this is mega country baby so i did this
that's my tag
i didn't broad daylight says trump the
thing is i need to get the 2020 deer
are they setting that on fire what are
they doing
oh no they're just spray painted
gina was the one who ran over and
actually did the tag
uh
it's all it's all very very strange they
added 2020 to trump what a bunch of
rebels yeah exactly exactly
here's an interesting super chat from
connor connor asks david what's your
opinion of sinks and showers and other
elements of bathrooms elements of
bathroom i i maintain my support of uh
indoor plumbing
um i am completely unfettered in my
support for indoor plumbing and i would
like to see it continue as an amenity
for uh for humans
i wanna say thanks to anthony webb for
the patreon pledge
those count double today so that puts us
at 51.
over on twitch i want to say thanks to
sado master christ
joseph rader and cappy b
for the twitch prime subscriptions
putting us at 54. we are getting very
close if we get to a hundred website
memberships and twitch subscriptions we
will open phone lines
and if we get to a thousand total on
twitch which is further up we will open
phone lines
we haven't done this in a while and
remember that you can sign up at
joinpakman.com with the coupon code
obama obama
exactly
all right let's do a few voicemails i
now have
905 unlistened to voicemails because
i've fallen so far behind i have other
things we're gonna get to including
someone playing drums to my theme song
okay we're gonna get to that just stand
by
but first let's listen to some of our
frequent callers here's eric from mass
hey david it's eric for math i got a
riddle for you ready good riddle here
what's the difference between
a conspiracy and a fact
about nine months um
okay
um
here's the egg man eggman had a run-in
with police check this out
dave i just pulled down at a gas station
i forgot to put on my seatbelt okay i
got pulled over by a cop
for that i told him officer it's against
my religion to wear a seatbelt
and then he said oh sir i'm totally
sorry go about your day have a good day
shalom brother sir sure yeah no that uh
that that makes a lot of sense
that that that really really does
um
let's see what else we've got here
uh
what else do i have there's so many
here's another i think this is a troy
york one hi david pacman um i think one
of the reasons uh
you have so many viewers in australia
new zealand canada
is because canada
they enjoy a leftist troll such as
yourself bash american republicans
and
likely the people you mentioned
that part of the audience is who you
curtail your anti-americanism and i
curtail it oh my god this guy does not
even know how language works okay
whitney did leave a string of voicemails
which i'm glad to play for you
so i was like looking online at more of
the
people who
are
talking about their personalities and
stuff
and what i noticed there's like the
personality type that's supposed to be
more like mine
and
um
what's happening is that
i'm looking at it like maybe
all right a couple others from whitney
so i was researching more about the
myers-briggs personalities yeah like the
last two weeks of voicemails from
whitney have been all about myers-briggs
and various personality tests
so anyways i was realizing that using
s e
more like tuning in more to my physical
environment has given me like this
mutated personality disorder oh my god
that's a problem
but having
um in business that being like a
commander personality or somebody that
you would look up to like normally i
don't think anybody would necessarily
pick
somebody who was an entj specifically i
wouldn't either yeah
hey david
i just wanted to let you know that um
your promotion of bitcoin yes it was
promotion right no matter what you say
talking about bitcoin
talking about the fact that you own it
talking about the fact that you'll buy
more
that's promotion david
uh
oh my god i don't do i even need to
address that like i don't even know what
the point you know it's like
i am transparent in my views on personal
finance and the my views basically are
you need to have the right asset
allocation for your level of risk
so i've i explained a couple days ago
stocks are down they're up i don't know
about timing the market so i'm not going
to try bitcoin's down it's up whatever
as i said before
i have made an asset allocation decision
it's not a market timing decision where
i go oh i'm going to buy right now and
sell right now i've decided that for my
risk tolerance
i want three to five percent of assets
in crypto i want the vast majority of my
assets in you know other things
wide
broad-based index funds mostly us with
some international and then bonds and
then you got real estate and then you
got cash
this is all really really simple stuff
i've been in crypto for so long that the
three to five percent
grew and became 10 so then i sell to
rebalance down to three to five percent
you do the same thing if stocks do
better than bonds you get overexposed to
stocks so then you put more into bonds
than stocks and you're regularly
rebalancing
if anybody wants to call that promoting
guess we have a disagreement about the
english language
um i don't know okay
let's see what else we've got here i do
have more whitney stuff
so i was just thinking about
the
i don't know exactly how to put it um
there's not like really words to
describe how weird the situation is here
in america
um like basically i feel like there's a
lot of people man these these really go
nowhere like they literally they last
the full three minutes and then time out
um i've got a ton of these from troy
york but they're just so boring that
it's like i don't even
i'm just i don't even know that i want
to get into it
all right yeah that's enough with
voicemails i don't think we have to do
any more cameron asked a good question
not sure if you already answered but do
you think biden and dem approval will
pause be positively affected by a
successful appointment to the supreme
court not not significantly i don't
think it will be significant
um david how are you it's been confusing
in the education field in new york state
with the constant ruling over masks in
schools recently i have to say i haven't
been following it closely
okay let's get to this this is cool a
drummer
did a video where they took my theme
song and they added drums and they have
my face in the background let's check it
out i'm gonna make this an intro soon
[Music]
wow that's good
[Music]
even the kick cam i like it
[Music]
oh and then the picture changes to one
where i really had a problem
this is extraordinarily well done
um i would actually suggest a full this
is tim
i would suggest a full length drum cover
of the theme song
and i think that we could make that one
of our stream intros let's take one more
listen
and by the way the pillow in the kick
drum that's my move as well i i always
had one in there for home home use
[Applause]
[Music]
all right excellent really really really
well done i absolutely love it hearing
you dismantle jordan peterson was truly
therapeutic says tristan i believe a
debate between you and him would be
helpful to the world
it's hard to debate with someone who
will speak in deliberately
unintelligible language
and um let's just do that i i have a
clip out on youtube about this but just
because i like you guys and we're here
um
this new interview with jordan peterson
and joe rogan
it's it it seems like a skit like it's a
it's it's
it just doesn't make any sense look at
this hard to sort out the climate change
one is a weird one so that one that's
because there's no such thing as climate
right climate and everything are the
same word
and i that's what bothers me about the
climate change type also why is he
wearing a tuxedo like i don't understand
anything about this like
this is something that bothers me about
it technically it's like
climate is about everything
it's okay
but your models aren't based on
everything your models are based on
a set number of variables why also does
anybody know why joe rogan says warming
oh he's saying your models are based
only on warming even that's not true
like it's just endlessly confusing yeah
so that means you've reduced the
variables which are everything
to that psychologist
like
i i'm even just thinking about it now
what like dude what are you talking
about set
well how did you decide which set of
variables to include in the equation if
it's about everything
and that's not just a criticism that's
like
if it's about everything your models
aren't right
because your models do not and cannot
model everything what do you mean by
everything
oh it's unbelievable um here's another
one i challenge any of you to decipher
this okay
so i just walked through the museum of
the bible in washington that was very
cool it's a very cool museum so the
structure that's what the box yeah is
what i figured out i mean i just figured
this out this week
so it was a cool
it was a cool thing to walk through
because
it's it's chronological they have one
floor which is the history of the bible
it's not exactly that it's really what
it is is the hist
it's already crazy he's like they have a
floor about the history of the bible but
it's not that they don't know that the
floor isn't even about what they think
it's about
he figured out what the floor is really
about and now he's going to tell us
history of the book
now in many ways the first book was the
bible i mean literally
because
at one point there was only one book
wait a second are you saying literally
or metaphorically our western culture is
concerned there was one book
and for a while literally there was only
one book and that book was the bible and
then before it was the bible it was a
you know scrolls and it was writings on
papyrus and but it was we were starting
to aggregate written texts together and
it went through all sorts of
technological transformations and then
it became
books that everybody could buy the book
everybody could buy and the first one of
those was the bible and then it became
all sorts of books that everybody could
buy
wait so it is more than one book but now
are we saying it's more than one book
literally or it's more than one book
metaphorically
but all those books in some sense
emerged out of that underlying book and
that book itself the bible isn't a book
it's a library oh so the entire
isn't that the best so we're not even
talking about a book neither now is it
literally a library or is it
metaphorically a library i don't know at
this point in time
um
this could be an snl skit
um
he replaced benzos with cannabis yeah i
don't know
it's
it's really crazy it's really crazy and
i saw a good comment scroll by on on
twitch
um
which is a really good one hold on a
second where was it here
that was a great comment oh yeah this is
of vergimp said this this is how the
right works they have a talking head
that represents the intelligentsia of
their movement and the base just follows
them yeah that's that's a simplified
version of uh
kind of what i'm talking about
um
okay all right good
does he think the world has a scribe
they were loose stories that were
grouped way later yeah it doesn't even
really it's just it's it's crazy um
and sometimes i think it's kind of like
on purpose
i want to say thank you to christopher
bailey for signing up on my website with
the coupon code obama obama
christopher's new member number 55 today
also want to say thanks to skittle stew
for the twitch prime
sub and you are number 56 we still have
the possibility of opening the phone
lines today and hearing from you guys
but we've gotta move on it we either
have to get to a hundred website members
and twitch subscribers or to a thousand
total on twitch we're at 968.
if we do that we will open phone lines
but we should do it soon we should do it
soon all right let's go to a couple of
other things okay we did this
um oh okay here's another angle on the
anti-mask stuff which is um
disabilities where they sort of like
allude to ada the americans with
disabilities act but it's never clear
like what what exactly are you talking
about and they seem to be doing that
which they criticize others for doing
the right loves to say
anybody can just claim disabilities
and it's bogus but then here they want
to claim disabilities without explaining
what they are which they claim to be
against let's watch this one did you
guys try to donate your books yet did
they accept it no yes the woman has a
book that says jesus calling and i guess
they're here to donate books without
masks okay okay not yet okay
yeah they're denying people service when
they're asking for help to pick out a
book
so if we can get a blast out to help out
with that ada paperwork i think that
would be eight we need to get a blast
out to help with the ada paperwork
what
yeah it's great right between the two of
us i feel like between the two
the police were saying that it is not a
law yeah and
then hey how are you
um support the men and women yeah and
they said it's more like a policy like
no shirt no shoes no service you don't
have to wear a mask it's a policy
um
right policies you have to abide by
right
but they can like they can have like you
remove for trespassing but you might not
be no cited i think they had a
conversation there's a level of smugness
here that is that is something else yeah
i agree with you guys what does that
actually look like and is that fruitful
in this situation right and um
they left so
unless they're coming back with some
bigger forces
and like a bus to put us in i don't know
like i just assumed that
they said bye like they're like later
meanwhile we're gonna exercise our
you know ready to be over there
it's funny she says we're gonna exercise
our and then it's like you can see the
gr the gears grinding to life very rusty
gears she's like wait a second it's not
a first amendment right really because
it's not that doesn't make sense it's
not really a second amendment because i
don't have my guns here wait what i'm
going to exercise just my ability to be
here it's an exercise in entitlement
quite frankly yes
you and i need more things to do i feel
like we should just pick a library each
week and do it
right
the path came to talk to us
he just said i'm not going to ask
anybody
wow what a moral victory they found an
employee here
who is not going to ask anybody okay so
these people are deeply deeply ill
um
here is fox
propagandist tucker carlson
hosting the wrongest man of the pandemic
alex berenson who's now calling for
all
covet vaccines
to be pulled
he just wants him pulled
uh it's we're at a very dangerous moment
tucker and you know i i i'm not excited
i want him
this is a this is a perfect opportunity
to mention an article that i if any of
you like to read
let me find i'm going to show you an
article um
this is a tremendous article i would
love for you to check out
and him saying this is very dangerous
just reminded me of it we're going to
get back to that
seth moskowitz
the reactionary trap
which explains
the tendency towards reactionary
thinking
on right and left
it relates to the issue of audience
capture
it relates to the issue of preying on
the idea of fear
anyway this is a really good article
just search for seth moscow it's the
reactionary trap but that's part of
what's going on here
it's in its it's extremely dangerous
here
glenn greenwald did the exact same thing
the other day
okay
um let me see if i can grant glenn
greenwald ducey he did the exact and i
played this clip check this out
hello everyone this is glenn greenwald
and today is a
dark and
really dangerous day for press freedom
no it's not glenn no it's not america a
hard-working journalist peter ducey did
nothing more than go to work today to do
his job he went to the white house to
ask a question of the most powerful
political official
on the planet president biden a question
and this is anyway it's an incredibly
dark day for press freedom no it's not
biden lost his temper and said something
stupid john mccain also called peter
duchy an idiot or whatever and said it
was the stupidest question he had ever
heard
um joe biden is not trying to take press
credentials away joe biden does not say
the media is the enemy of the people you
know it's like it's and this this is the
reactionary trap so i really encourage
people to read this article it's a very
very good article we're going to try to
get seth on the show to talk about it
anyway let's continue most important
appearance i've had with you in the last
two years
it is it is completely clear now that uh
the vaccines don't really work at all
against omicron now that's of course
untrue that's a lie
um the truth is
that the current vaccines are
significantly less effective at
preventing infection from omicron
they are still
our best
and an effective tool
to keep you out of the hospital and to
keep you alive the data are very clear
about that it's incontrovertible data
but but it doesn't matter
tucker is hosting this by the way just
about everybody at fox news is
vaccinated fox news is one of the
strictest policies of any company in the
us in in in these highly vaccinated and
highly boosted countries uh rates of
infection are incredibly high and rates
of serious disease and death are also
the israelis are predicting that they're
going to have more serious cases than
they ever had at the peak last year now
understand he's going from rate to total
number
everybody's getting a ton of serious
cases
but the rate is lower because omicron
appears to be significantly less severe
new estimates are
that we could actually be down to the
same mortality rate as flu slightly
higher i saw a report that says we're
down to 0.2 percent flu is 0.15
but if it's so contagious that so many
people are getting it in raw number
right i mean what does he care who am i
even talking to you guys know
um
and the idea that we would solve this
with another booster is is just off the
charts insane and again
increasingly the the what we're learning
is no no fourth shot no fourth shot
we
are going to have a modified vaccine
specific to omicron in two months
but who is he saying is saying everybody
got a fourth shot
i have not said this to you before
because i'm pretty careful and i'm
pretty careful with the data but these
vaccines these mrs this is the guy who
said the us will not see 500 000 deaths
we're at 900 000 deaths really careful
with the data vaccines the mrna cova
vaccines need to be withdrawn from the
market now no one should get them no one
should get boosted no one should get
double boosted
they are a dangerous and ineffective
product at this point against omacrom
the spike that they make your body make
that you then produce antibodies to is
not the omicron spike and earlier today
tony fauci said we're not going to give
people monoclonal antibody products
because the first generation products
because they don't work against the
omicron spike the same logic applies to
these mrna vaccines and giving people
boosters even if in the very short term
it knocks down infection rates there's a
boomerang effect and that's what they're
seeing in all these countries we're at a
dangerous moment and these products need
to be withdrawn okay everything he said
is uh crazy that is just completely and
totally bonkers what he said and uh
i do a full debunk in a clip that we're
going to publish very soon but that
that's what's going on there i want to
say thanks to to
toil
avalanche of spinach
as well for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 58. also a
big thank you to
canope who just signed up on my website
using the coupon code uncharged pickles
uncharged piccolos and his new member
number 59 today i really appreciate that
all right swami says david sir you skip
past my last two super chats i'm okay
and will continue to support you through
elements of donations i apologize the
the entire super chat system is is
broken
to where if i don't see it and click it
it it goes away within like five minutes
so i really apologize but i appreciate
your support i also want to say thanks
to captain smiles who just gifted 10
twitch subs putting us at 69. all right
by popular demand by popular demand
we are going to review a short interview
that jesse waters did
with an anti-woke anti-work
dog walker
um that i am told went horribly wrong
let's check it out over 1.6 million
subscribers
joining me now is the person who
operates this anti-work group doreen
ford
all right so doreen
why do you like the idea
of
being home not working
but still getting paid
first of all it's like
who wouldn't like the idea of that right
i mean that's like well
i don't know it sounds pretty good you
just you just don't work and you get
paid it sounds good it's a very dumb
question by corporate
america yeah uh so there's some
misconceptions about the movement um so
we're a movement where we want to reduce
the amount of work that people feel like
they they're forced to to do um and so
we want to still put an effort we want
to put in labor
but we don't want to necessarily
uh be in a position where we feel
trapped you know you just quoted from
office space where that person feels
very trapped in their job i think we're
calling for a society where there's less
of that um but yeah absolutely people
still want to do things they just want
to do things where they feel
rewarded and they feel like they're in a
good spot in their life
and that their job respects them and
stuff like that um you know there's
varying so you're
so doreen you're not being forced to
work this isn't this isn't slave labor
you've you've applied for a job
now see here's the thing with this stuff
like obviously this doreen ford
is not i mean okay so so like let's
let's step back
this interview is a sandbag this
interview is just an interview it's
three minutes long very few people who
are not on tv all the time can come off
looking good if given only three minutes
to answer extremely narrow questions
but even the and and you know i'm all
about
work and you know self-determination
whatever if people don't want to work
then great don't work and you know
whatever but
jesse waters is being either ignorant or
or kind of insincere disingenuous in
that this whole thing of no one's
forcing you to work
okay you're not being forced to work but
unless you're independently wealthy we
have a system where
you have to somehow provide for yourself
and so like that doesn't mean you're a
slave at a particular job but it's not a
very realistic conversation
his framing is bad faith
doreen has no business doing this
interview there's no it's beyond any
doubt okay i agree with that
but
this is not a good faith conversation
about the ways in which even if you're
not a slave to a particular job
there's a system
in which
you don't even get health care unless
you okay you know right where that's a
legitimate conversation to have um
anyways it's like it's bad faith versus
completely unprepared you know agreed to
the terms and conditions of the
employment
and
you know you can walk away from that job
at any time and quit so
i don't understand really what this is
about except it sounds like maybe people
are just being lazy are you encouraging
people to be lazy
um so i think laziness is um a virtue in
a society where
people constantly want you to be
productive 24 7 and it's good to have
rest um that doesn't mean you should be
resting all the time or not putting
effort into things that you care about
but i think one of those what do you
think is like a good work day how many
hours is is you know a solid work day in
your ideal society
uh sure i mean i think as much as people
want i mean i personally uh work painful
both because doreen is very unprepared
but because the premise of the interview
is so bad faith and jesse waters is so
gross i have i have like a 20 25 hour
work weeks which i think is fairly good
um so i would like less work hours
doreen
i'm a dog walker a dog walker okay yes
and uh yeah so how old are you if you
don't mind me asking
sure i'm 30. you're 30. okay
and is there something you want to do
besides being a dog walker do you aspire
to do anything more than dog walking or
is that kind of your
your pinnacle
uh i i like that that's irrelevant to
the points being made you know it's like
everything about this is just so stupid
working with dogs if i had to do this
for us for my life you know i wouldn't
be super complaining you know dogs are
wonderful animals uh but i mean i would
love to teach uh i would love to
um you know
work with work with people and stuff
like that what would you teach
dorian uh a philosophy mostly
philosophy critical thinking reason
stuff like that okay
well i would love to take your class
doreen
i would just
be taking notes the whole time and you
know what a professor is a very similar
schedule than
something that you're
imagining so i think that actually might
might work perfectly for you listen uh i
think this might not be the greatest
idea but who am i to judge
to each their own they say it's a free
country
sure not everything's free
but it is a free country thank you so
much we gotta run we gotta pay the bill
i mean it's such it's such a dumb
interview you know
um
and i get that i get that doreen is
completely unprepared for this but it's
just all very stupid
sager says this interview went so
horribly wrong that the anti-work
subreddit has been shut down and likely
for good is that true the subreddit it's
shut down
why did it get did it get brigaded or
something that's crazy i don't
understand why this interview would end
up with it shut down
it's private okay all right
um david sir what do you think about
katie porter or al franken for president
in 2024 uh yeah neither has a shot
unfortunately
um
i feel the only way biden has a chance
is to legalize marijuana and drop
student debt yeah neither of which he's
gonna do so
unfortunate all right guys we've got
some exciting stuff going on here
belly hair designs gel b
jhtm and gender fluid lion
have gotten twitch prime subs putting us
at 73
and skittle stew has gifted 25 putting
us at 98
and putting us over a thousand oh my god
i've got to like tweak my little thing
here
because uh hold on a second can we
because we can't even see
wait a second where is it
there we go we are now over a thousand
for the first time in a while on twitch
and i promised i would open phone lines
if that happened and i'm gonna stick to
that also toil has gifted two jhtm has
gifted two that puts us at 102. this is
an historic day
this is truly an historic day okay
before we open phone lines just real
quick i people said they loved
geoguesser the other day so let's play
geoguessr we'll play
together we will play together let's try
it this is where you were dropped in
somewhere in the world and we've got
five minutes to figure out where we are
let's see okay
we've got farmland
uh it looks like there's a giraffe so
that should be a signal giraffes are
only in certain parts of the world
this could really be absolutely anywhere
let's see if we can get
somewhere else
because there is very little here that
is telling me much at all
um
let's look at if we can find the street
name
oh man i can't see that let's see
wreath single okay
so i'm thinking this is probably
europe or a european colony
uh
could be
could be germany
let's see what else we've got
elsa okay this is looking like germany
could be austria
let's take a look at what else we can
find
oh okay here we go here we've got some
substance
toxienes
spar
is this german or is this oh no it's
dutch see that okay it's the netherlands
beautiful it's the netherlands
so we've narrowed it down to the
netherlands now let's see if we can get
anything more
specific here
uh
do i go southwest
or do i go north oh northeast seems like
there might be more happening let's go
this way
um
kunstwerkin platz huh
i mean okay so we know i i i don't know
if i'm gonna be able to get any more
specific because i don't i've only been
to amsterdam and a few other to a few
other dutch
places really close by
i don't know that continuing is really
going to get me any closer
um
yeah i think i'm just going gonna go for
it so we will go with netherlands
now
what are you guys thinking north
south do i just go near amsterdam i
don't i don't know
south
south people are saying okay
let's go
let's go here here we go
oh i should have gone with amsterdam
you bastards i would have been so close
if i went with amsterdam because it is
actually really really close
you guys screwed me
that's really crazy 102 kilometers away
isn't too bad all right let's try one
more
wait isn't this the same one
oh no it's not okay speed limit sign and
corn are we thinking midwest guys speed
limit sign in corn midwest united states
let's head north
now unfortunately i only have a minute
and 43 seconds on this one
uh
oh boy
this looks like more of a main road oh i
can't even i'm not even allowed to go
that way that's crazy
people are saying iowa i mean it's
certainly very flat
the license plates are often blurred out
which makes it difficult to figure out
we just gotta get i mean yes this very
much could be iowa
look at this there's just nothing to
look at
this is crazy
can we even get to an intersection or
something
wow i've got one minute to go
nothing too much there
hmm
yeah i'm thinking iowa right now just
because of corn and how flat it is
but there is just nothing there's no
frame of reference here
from the speed limit signs i believe
it's the united states
rather than canada
let's see what we have here
man it's just there's just oh hold on
170 street does that do anything for
anyone 170 street
it's just corn it's cornville
cornville usa
we've just been on the same road forever
oh i ran out of time oh my god i'm an
idiot okay well let's see if it still
will let me make a guess
uh i'm just gonna say iowa let's see
it is indeed oh no wait a second
it's in
it's over the border into illinois all
right
309 kilometers from the correct location
that's not terrible
that's not terrible
um okay
all right i promise to open the phone
lines and i will do so right now i want
to say thanks to lord riley for an
additional twitch subscription
uh we are going to use discord you can
go to davidpakman.com
discord that's the place to go
um and we will uh be doing all of it
let's talk to some people you can get
into the waiting lobby if you would like
to talk to me
let's see what's on people's minds we'll
start here with ryan from portsmouth
ryan welcome what's on your mind today
not too much david how are you doing
today i'm doing well
good um just want to give you a small
update i'm actually a college professor
in uh the tidewater area in virginia um
and our beginning schedule got all sorts
of screwed up with kovid um
we had to basically go virtual for the
first two weeks right we're now actually
an in person right now so
it's a good thing we're in person um
we've actually got a pretty good policy
um
what is it i'm looking up here 94 of our
students are vaccinated 92 percent of
our faculty and employees are vaccinated
okay so
hopefully it's a good thing so
good yeah my mom teaches college they're
remote for the first two weeks in order
to get everybody like triple tested
basically
yeah and then it looks like they're
going to go back in person yeah
yeah um my question is this um did you
see the recent story about governor
youngkins
having an email tip line for divisive
yes teaching methods and i guess the
entire thing is just being trolled to to
oblivion
yeah i think i think it is now um i
think that a lot of people got in touch
with it and figured out oh want to
basically rack on features well no we're
going to talk about how great they are
we're going to fair a lot of stuff i
think my favorite thing was the article
that i read the very bottom of it said
critical race theory is not currently
taught in k-12 yeah according according
to the department of virginia education
i was like but what the hell do they
know you know yeah exactly no i'm sorry
anyways thank you so much david you're
doing great thank you so much for the
past two years all right ryan from
portsmouth virginia oh i wrongly assumed
it was portsmouth new hampshire now it
all makes a lot more sense i want to say
thanks to wp canada for signing up via
twitch prime with the message here's
some bezos bucks let's go next to haley
from georgia hayley you're on the air
hey david what's up how you doing
i'm great um i had a question for you
please do you think that
if the supreme court does overturn roe v
wade or you know banish it the law the
the the
you know the
starry diseases whatever however they
say it yeah if they change if they
create new precedent with a new with a
different ruling yeah
do you think that that might actually
work out better for
the democrats or the libs and whatever
because we might fight harder haley this
is a very astute a political observation
you're you're absolutely right it would
be a disaster so listen if if roe v wade
is effectively overturned as you're
pointing out it doesn't have to be
literally canceled but overturned by by
by new rulings
you will see abortion flat out banned in
a bunch of states it will remain legal
in a whole bunch of other states but
it will serve as a cultural flashpoint
for the left basically the right fights
the culture war essentially against no
one right i mean it's basically a war of
their own creation
i do think you're on to something that
it may
catalyze
um the left in a way we have not seen
for a long time now it would still be a
disaster for women everywhere but from a
political angle i i think your analysis
is quite astute
yeah and you know um when the right is
only about culture war they don't really
have policy anymore right um they don't
have roe v wade to fight about anymore
it's gone that that that whole talking
point is gone
you are absolutely right
yeah well thanks so much for talking to
me david all right haley thank you for
the call very much appreciate it
um let's uh let's hear from a couple
other people let's go to anibal from
guatemala you know one of my uncle's
middle name is anibal
sorry can you hear me i can hear you
oh great
this is maybe the fifth time i'm trying
to talk to you but always happens
something like
my internet just get down or i can
unlock my cell phone it's just the worst
thing ever well i'm glad you're here
so i am from guatemala yes
so
uh guatemala now have one of the worst
political times
i only kind
kind
give the g
ah sorry sorry my english sometimes gay
you're doing great we can even do it in
spanish if you prefer and i can
translate
great ah sorry sometimes i forget it
is
so the question generally here is what
is joe biden's outlook and policy
perspective on central america that
republicans have led to
uh
they've certainly not reduced the amount
of corruption in guatemala and that
every time it seems there may be an
opportunity for joe biden to do or say
something about central america
um something happens ukraine blows up
there's a coup attempt somewhere or
whatever the case may be now
i hate to give such an anti-climactic
answer and one that is quite frankly
very disappointing but
i don't think joe biden really
prioritizes central america and i don't
think joe biden has any particular plan
in terms of dealing with central america
uh there are certain things that joe
biden pretends to care about like
you know decriminalizing marijuana or
forgiving student loan debt that i never
believed he actually cared about and
then there's things joe biden isn't even
really pretending to care about he'll
occasionally talk about guatemala
honduras and you know the region i just
don't think this is really on biden's
radar between covid russia ukraine a
tough midterm
i i wish i had a different answer i
don't think biden has any real hard and
fast ideas about what his administration
will do in central america
well now
for me it's just please
try to look up for guatemala um try to
be
okay so the last thing that anibal said
is guatemala ends up being a sort of
chess piece
in a game
used to the advantage of different
individuals and i think that that is
something we have seen quite a bit we
have seen quite a bit over time all
right let's go back to english
with
where are we going next let's go to kion
from north carolina keon you're on the
air
hello how you doing i'm doing well keon
welcome
oh man
i was so excited well
you know i was i was just talking about
you well um uh here's my question please
so
i'm very interested in like military
affairs and stuff like that and i mean
military tech and stuff but
um my question is what do you think
do you think ukraine should have kept
their nuclear weapons
instead of giving them up because
now they're dealing with the problem
of potential
i'm not saying it's going to actually
happen but
i mean
with as many troops as
putin got along the border
he might invade and that's my fear
um do you think that uh ukraine
should've
dismantled that nuclear weapons do you
think that was a good idea or do you
think it was a bad idea this is a
fascinating question keon this this may
be a perfect question okay
this is this is such an interesting
thing you know when i'm gonna get back
to ukraine and nuclear weapons but when
we think about
uh when we think about
um north korea for example and their
nuclear ambitions and our desire for
them to say we're not going to do it
we're not going to do it when you look
historically it sort of makes a lot of
sense that countries would want and
would try to have nuclear weapons chat
correct me if i'm wrong
saddam had nukes and gave them up right
i mean like this is the prototypical
story where
uh i think
we would all agree
that had saddam not given up the nuclear
program maybe he didn't have nukes but
he had to get a pro nuclear program
right i i i've not reviewed the history
for a while
obviously
the two wars on iraq would have gone
differently like it's just it
yeah i am for nuclear disarmament i hate
nuclear weapons there's no realistic way
that we're gonna have a nuclear war but
it's undeniable
that other countries relate to you
differently when you have them so do i
oh now people are saying iraq did not he
he didn't
he didn't really choose to give them up
but they did someone else saying iraq
didn't have the ability to launch them
but they were working on it and they had
material okay the point here is
it changed the course of the global
communities dealing with iraq so
do i want anybody to have nukes no i'd
rather nobody have nukes but
would ukraine's
circumstances
have been different had they not
um done away with their nuclear arsenal
at the time or shortly thereafter of the
dissolution of the soviet union i'm
going from memory i don't remember
exactly but it was a you know they they
had about a third of the arsenal of the
soviet arsenal and they gave it up
i think it's undeniable that over the
last 30 years things would have gone
differently in ukraine is that sort of
an answer
yeah
uh oh
hello
yellow
oh man
all right keon we lost you um but that
was a very very good question and i
really really appreciate it
let's go next to sean from maryland sean
you were on the air
hey david
uh actually i was wondering if you were
in um
like outside like aside from the
voicemails uh touch with whitney and if
so would you be interested in doing a dr
k
kind of situation with her i am not in
touch with her independent of the
voicemails and i would be glad to do the
dr k stuff
uh if everybody felt
sorry what was that
if everybody
hold on i'm gonna talk okay give me let
me talk let me talk then you go okay
okay
if everybody felt good that it was not
exploitative because i don't know
whitney's mental state i would be glad
to do that if dr k was amenable to it
that's fair is that fair
totally okay
anything else today sean
no all right i was just like i really
enjoyed that it kind of gave us uh some
really interesting insights
to some of your more regular um
uh callers in and uh voicemail
personalities i guess i agree but i i
definitely agree like the
the
making sure that it's not uh
exploitative is pretty key yeah exactly
so i'd have to figure out maybe dr k
would have to do a pre-interview with
whitney or who knows but we'll explore
we'll explore
cool all right all right sean from
maryland thank you for the call very
much appreciate that's a very fair
question i mean we just want to make
sure everything's being done uh
correctly and on the up and up i want to
say thanks to hippie chick for the
twitch prime subscription
um already part of our 106 there
let's uh hear from a couple of other
people here we're taking calls via
discord let's go to sid vicious from
hawaii sid vicious you were on
hi how's it going it's going
uh man i i was actually i wanted to
comment on your last uh the second last
call about the
nuclear program that okay uh iraq
yeah they were building the sov the
french designed the plant and the
soviets built it but under an operation
by the uh
israeli air force it was destroyed so
nothing
nothing really came
from that and uh it was basically they
flew the israeli air force flew
uh jets at a very low altitude over
jordan
and they they reached iraq and they
destroyed the plants so
i don't know if that helps with the
point that you were making you know i
i'm actually now thinking i i think i
was thinking more about the disarmament
of libya under gaddafi does that make
more sense because that would have been
that would have been around the same
time i believe it was the early 2000s
when qaddafi agreed to get rid of the
nuke program and then we know how that
ended up you know
yeah he did willingly actually he was
very cooperative at first
there were several visits by a few
british
i think or one or two british prime
ministers back in the early 2000s or in
the mid 2000s yeah uh to libya so he was
very cooperative if anything so i think
i basically got my examples mixed up the
analysis is the analysis i said but i
think i meant to apply it to qadhafi and
not to to saddam
that's that's exactly it well i
appreciate you taking time out to hear
my quality well sid vicious i appreciate
the correction thank you so much uh
really a very very
important one for sure
let's check in with ellie from seattle
ellie you're on the air
oh hey david sorry a little uh
starstruck here
um i i was watching your show yesterday
you were talking about um the situation
with ukraine and russia yes um
and how everyone
or a lot of people don't seem all that
interested in it you know they were way
more interested in biden calling the
reporter a son of a [ __ ] right and
you know i guess my question is like how
do we get people you know more
interested in this stuff do we have to
put on like some dog and pony show or i
really don't know ellie you know i mean
it's like you look at you look at our
video clips and we obviously the all of
the sort of policy and foreign policy
um clips
have they require a lot more research
and you just look at you know you look
at how well these clips do and it's like
you know a hundred thousand views two
hundred thousand views i'm looking on my
phone three hundred thousand views and
then it's like you know ukraine clip
barely anything people are not paying
attenti this is a this is an ongoing
issue and i quite frankly don't have the
answer
yeah i mean we can't even get people to
believe in science so how do we get them
to care about foreign policy i agree
with you i agree with you it's very very
difficult and uh you know also the other
aspect of this is there's there's a lot
of people who think that just mentioning
countries sort of like counts as uh
foreign relations like we played this
clip on monday of joni ernst being asked
what would republicans do if you won in
november
and one of the things she listed was
they would do foreign relations as if
that counts as anything you know it's
crazy
it's all just a bunch of words salad
they're just like blowing hot air
you know that doesn't really mean
anything but people fill in the blanks
however they want to and
it garners support and it's toxic really
it really is and i i wish i had
solutions here but i really am lacking
them
yeah well thanks david all right my
pleasure uh great great question from
ellie there
uh that is going to do it for me today
folks we are going to wrap today's
stream we've got the trump rally
saturday we'll have a correspondent on
the ground and it's just it's truly
incredible what's going on
so i appreciate everybody who joined me
we will be back maybe tomorrow friday
but at minimum
big event on saturday and we will ban
men exactly and we will be back with
everybody very very soon